في المقابل
مستشار حاكم الموالي لروسيا ان القوات
الاوكرانيه هجمت سفينه مدنيه في مضيق
كيريتش واضاف جاجين ان الهدف من الهجوم هو
التغطيه على اخفاقات اوكرانيه في المعارك
وتوجيه رساله لممولها لانها تحقق نتائج
على الجبهه حسب تعبيره
تعرضت سفينه مدنيه تحمل طاقم مدنيا وتنفذ
مهمه مدنيه للقصف انا مقتنع بان الهجوم
على الناقله المدنيه في مضيق كرش هو
استفزاز من قبل كييف العدو كان هدفه قصف
جسر القرم والمرافق المدنيه ويريد التغطيه
على اخفاقاته في الجبهه وتوجيها رساله
لمموله الغربيين بانه يحقق نتائج على
الارض لكنه يتكبد خسائر ونحن في موقع
دفاعي قويا ونستنزف قدراته
بدايه معك نور الدين تفضل
نعم سفيان يبدو ان الحدث الابرز الان هو
الهجوم الذي تتعرض له المواقع الروسيه في
البحر الاسود وفي مضيق كرش الحديث هنا في
روسيا ان هذه الاهداف التي يتم استهدافها
من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه ليست ضمن نطاق
المواقع العسكريه او مواقع الدعم اللوجستي
بل هي اهداف مدنيه هكذا تحدث مستشار حاكم
اقليم دونيات الموالي لروسيا حينما يقول
بان ما تم استهدافه اليوم في مضيق كرتش هي
سفينه مدنيه عليها طاقم مدني وذات اغراض
مدنيه وللاغراض المدنيه وبالتالي حينما
يتم الحديث الان على الاستهدافات التي
تقوم بها روسيا اوكرانيا سواء بالبحر
الاسود او الامتداد على الحدود مع
اوكرانيا في كورسك وبريانسك كل هذه كل هذه
المناطق الان الحديث الروسي على ان هذه
الاهداف هي اهداف مدنيه ولم تصل بعد الى
الاهداف العسكريه ولا تدخل ضمن النطاق
العسكري ومن هنا
التهديد الروسي للجانب الاوكراني قد تبين
وتبين بشكل واضح من خلال تصريح نائب رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي الروسي لمترميدف الذي
يبدو من كلامه يرفع نبره التهديد وربما
اكثر من ذلك يرفع نبره نقل المواجهه من
مواقع خط الاشتباك القائمه الان ما بين
القوات الروسيه والقوات الاوكرانيه الى
مواقع اشتباك جديده ربما قد تصل الى
المناطق المتاخمه للحدود البولنديه هكذا
فهم ما قاله ديمتري في تغريده له حينما
قال بانه اذا كانت اوكرانيا تفكر في تلويت
مياه المنطقه ومياه البحر الاسود فيجب ان
تنتظر ان يتم تلويت المناطق التي يمكن ان
تسيطر عليها وانت انت تقع تحت سيطره
القوات البولنديه وبالتالي هو يتحدث عن
المناطق الغربيه لاوكرانيا والمتاخمه اذا
ربما هناك استراتيجيه عسكريه قد يتحرك على
اساسها الروس باستهداف ربما قد تشكل منطقه
تهديد للقوات الاوكرانيه سواء كما كنا
نقول سابقا تلك التي تنطلق منها المسيرات
او تلك التي تتمركز بها قوات الجنود وخاصه
ما تسميهم روسيا بالمرتزقه وهنا الحديث
باتجاه الصومي وباتجاه خركيب وكذلك على
مستوى مستودعات الصواريخ المتطوره او
هيمارس لكن بكل تاكيد سفيان هناك تطورات
ميدانيه ربما تجعل الجانب الروسي يتحرك
بشكل اسرع لاحكام سيطرته على العديد من
المناطق ربما الهدف الان في اتجاه الجنوب
كما يتحدث القاده الروس هنا هي محاوله
عرقله اي تقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه فيزا وفي
خرسون وتقول القوات الروسيه بانها استطاعت
بشكل او باخر ان تمنع اي تقدم لهذه القوات
لكن اللافت كذلك والاهم هو اعلان القوات
الروسيه عن سيطرتها على مناطق باتجاه وهذا
ما يعني محاوله تطويقها لخر كيف
ومحاوله تطويقها لما تبقى من منطقه وهذا
ما قالت هو وزاره الدفاع والمتحدث باسم
وزاره الدفاع في هذا السياق